honored walk walk walk is lon lon gene
watches have 110 World's Fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other time
T's lon gene the world's most honored
watch is made in guaranteed by the lawn
gene with no watch company it's time for
the launching from esco a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour brought to you every Monday
Wednesday and Friday a presentation of
the lawn gene which nor wats company
maker of launching the world's most
honored wats and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lon gene
good evening this is frank night may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the Long gene Cronus cope mr.
Donald I Rogers an editor of the New
York Herald Tribune and mr. william
bradford huie editor of the American
mercury our distinguished guest for this
evening is mr. George a sloan chairman
of the United States Council of the
International Chamber of Commerce the
opinions discussed are necessarily those
of the speakers mr. slow and I'm sure
that our audience would like you to tell
us first what is the International
Chamber of Commerce safe mr. Huey of the
International Chamber of Commerce is a
group of National Committee's a
businessman in some faded nations of the
world in this country we have about 400
business firms in the United States it's
an organization of world businessman
designed to promote world trade that's
correct sir aunt designed primarily to
promote United States trade No an
international group designed to promote
international trade would would have
played for movement
across the barriers of different nations
now are we today are we Americans
selling a great deal of goods abroad not
today as much as we normally would in
peace times I see are we shipping a
great deal abroad under the aid program
oh yes yes indeed and what American
industries are most concerned with
foreign trades what American products
are going overseas now in the largest
quantities well in the in the export
field I would say normally or electrical
manufactures parama beals the the rubber
industry and some text tools is those
machines and so on is their resistance
abroad to American products coming into
those countries not resistance on the
part of the consumers i think is a great
desire for many american products abroad
but there's difficulty in buying those
players they like dollars exactly well
in order for those countries european
countries france england to buy american
goods they must first get dollars and in
order to get dollars they must first
sell their goods in the United States is
metro that is true when they sell their
goods in the United States do we not
bring about some harm to local
industries to domestic industry
generally speaking know if our entire
economy benefits why it's best for
America I have in mind the wool of Great
Britain or the woolen Goods of Great
Britain they constitute the largest
single export of Britain to the United
States last year do not our local woman
and worsted industries object to large
imports of British woman woods yes I
think they do I think you have hit upon
an exception to the general rule you
might have picked the cheese industry
and you wouldn't have the same problem
but I think that our reciprocal trade
agreement arrangements other the state
department offers a mean
of straightening out those problems
where they exist our our people sir I
believe you will agree i think a great
deal about World Trade and after the two
wars why we've had a great deal of
experience with it now in your vast
experience sir is there more enthusiasm
in America today for World Trade are our
people interested in trading with the
rest of the world more today than
they've been at any other time i should
say definitely they are mr. Huey I think
if there's any one reason that it's let
has brought the need of that world trade
home tour more than anything else
there's the heavy tax bill that's
necessary for the sending of billions of
dollars in relief and grants and and
economic aid in different kinds so they
are beginning to realize that that the
only way only thing that can take the
place of that relief is more trade and
the selling of more goods to American so
they'll have more of our industries
allow that sir when our industries allow
that yes well where the shoe pinches as
i said before where it where it's a
matter of serious unemployment in an
industry from that kind of competition
why they have recourse to through the
reciprocal trade arrangement and through
all tariffs commissions and so on now
you are interested and engaged in
promoting the total volume of World
Trade aren't you i ministered in
promoting two-way trade exactly between
the Freemasons in order as a means of
preserving the peace any regard trade
itself is hopeful is possibly
contributing to world peace I can't
think of anything that there that in a
practical way short of building up
armament for military defense I can't
think of anything that's more conducive
to world peace now our people mr. Sloane
you recall at the end of the first war
we had something like to smooth hole a
tariff act and it was terrific
resistance in America
to world trade now do you think that
that resistance is largely disappeared
or I don't know that its larger to
disappeared I think that that resistance
is great your lesson yes and and you
think that the principle of reciprocal
trade meaning the principle of accepting
that we must trade with the rest of the
world we must let them sell here as well
as their goods to them you think that
that's firmly accepted in the united
states now I think it's firmly accepted
in in all major industries by the
leaders in those industries how about
the American consumers do you think that
they are convinced unless you call
American taxpayers are they convinced
that we must have two-way trade between
nations otherwise we are going to have
to support Europe through such devices
as ECA or the Marshall Plan well I think
you have given the answer in the latter
part of your statement I think that it's
a that as this this heavy aid program we
have we have had through Marshall aid
and so on which was very essential has
convinced them that there must be some
other answer is a special now Marshall
aid yes nothing like the extent to which
it was beginning I look upon Marshall
aid as very essential pump right well is
it essential to the extent of seven and
a half billion dollars as we have
appropriated in 1951 I don't think so i
think that it was correct in 1951 when
we hear that the administration is
thinking of a similar amount for 1952 I
think you're getting away from the
principle of pump priming and I think
you are you you're running grave danger
there causing the people abroad become
too accustomed to this help and to get
away from self help so you you on that
point sir you're in favor of cutting
Marshall aids abstraction Utley in half
for 1952 I think the mutual aid program
should be cut approximately in half and
right now our American people have
always like to think that we are self
a satisfied country that we don't have
to import raw materials now are we
importing large amounts of raw materials
today sir I'm also glad you raised that
question because it's one of the
strongest proofs of the need of
international trade mr. Hewitt we are
absolutely dependent upon imports of 10
rohr some ninety-seven percent of it
comes from abroad we import a very
substantial amount of our bauxite needs
for the aluminum industry some forty
seven percent from abroad and so on and
we are even importing oil I believe
today we are I can't give you the
percentages but we are importing oil is
it true that our steel industry couldn't
exist without its imports of various
minor metals that go understandably in
the manganese about a hundred percent
from foreign countries without it we
couldn't not I knew that in mr. Rogers
we are coming to the end someday and in
the future and not too distant YouTube
our iron ore reserves in this country
that's why you see the steel industry
going to Labrador today exploring the
possibilities there and you will see the
US Steel Corporation going to Venezuela
then this isn't pure alto as we're
looking out of the United States you're
looking just right Oh Sam and and and
the people of this country I'm sure that
our audience would like your prediction
sir you don't think that we're going to
have anything like a high American
tariff at this period deliberately
designed to curtail the sales of foreign
goods in the United States no I don't
think so I don't think we'll ever return
to smoot-hawley tariff you think that we
as a people we've reached that we've
also reached a period in our development
as a nation when many of our resources
are being exhausted and we aren't we
must have raw materials beyond our own
geographical boundaries so you think
that it's intelligent selfishness on our
part to develop World Trade don't you
enlightened self-interest
and running quickly to the ECA do you
feel that the ECA is being administered
adequately a fairly with competence in
Europe or mr. Rogers when you say
hicieron you might imply you two ladies
here such terminated quite recently I
think they they've done a remarkably
good job I think though that that in all
of our efforts abroad in the nature of
economic aid we have so many men that
have become more or less professionals
in this matter of giving away American
money and not American patriotism well
and they're losing their knowledge of
economics I'm afraid and I'm not
concentrating as much thought on helping
those countries to help themselves as
they are in just learning how to give
away money yes mr. Sloane I'm sure that
our audience has appreciated your view
is a great deal tonight and thank you
for being with us sir the editorial
board for this edition of the lawn gene
Cronus cope was mr. Donald I Rogers and
mr. william bradford huie our
distinguished guest was mr. George a
Sloane chairman of the United States
Council of the International Chamber of
Commerce